this is a photo of my mother shizuko Ina
she was called to report to this Center
in San Francisco Japantown so she's
standing in line waiting to get her
family number on a card by which they
would be identified for the rest of the
time that they're incarcerated she's
pregnant with my older brother in that
photo my name is Satsuki Ina I was born
in the Thule Lake concentration camp
during World War II Satsuki Ina's mother
she's a go was one of 120 000 Japanese
Americans incarcerated in concentration
camps during World War II Satsuki told
me over the phone that when this photo
was taken in April 1942 her mother was
living in San Francisco that sign on the
wall behind her is a notice posted by
the U.S army instructing all people of
Japanese descent living in the area to
register themselves and their families
for evacuation or face criminal penalty
but addressed it to aliens and
non-aliens and non-alien is of course a
citizen this photo was taken by Dorothea
Lang one of the Great American
photographers of the 20th century Lang
took hundreds of photos of Japanese
Americans in 1942 but her images
remained mostly unseen until decades
later the government was so effective at
distorting the true Narrative of what
they did why they did it and what
happened to the people
[Music]
Japanese Americans had been segregated
from White American culture going back
to the first arrival of Japanese
immigrants in the late 1800s and faced a
wave of anti-japanese legislation
starting in the 1920s but after Japan's
bombing of the U.S Navy base at Pearl
Harbor a surprise attack that left over
2 000 Americans dead Japanese Americans
became targets of violence and increased
suspicion within hours of the attack FBI
agents showed up in the Japanese
American communities and removed the
essay first generation men who had been
already listed as potential threats
before the war broke out they were
labeled enemy aliens along with some
German and Italian Nationals and were to
be interned for the duration of the war
they felt that that would remove the
leadership and so the masses of Japanese
could not act in concert against the U.S
interests Gary okahiro is a scholar and
author whose work going back to the
1970s helped Pioneer the academic field
of Asian American studies they were
satisfied with the removal of just the
leaders of the Japanese American
community and their detention not a mass
removal but the politicians intervened
even though the Japanese American
leadership was already interned
newspapers and politicians started
stoking the fear of a new threat the
fifth column
the Trojan Horse the fifth column A
fifth column is a generic term that
refers to a group within a wartime
country secretly loyal to the enemy a
hypothetical Japanese fifth column was
invented in newspapers and was used by
politicians to justify anti-japanese
rhetoric Jack
were identified as
they were depicted as Insidious and as
threats to the government so there was a
kind of shift in public opinion even
though the fifth column didn't exist the
idea of it was powerful enough for the
American public to demand the government
do something drastic and in February
1942 the Roosevelt administration did
bypassing Executive Order 9066 which
empowered the Army to forcibly remove
anyone deemed a threat from strategic
military areas in this case the entire
west coast of the United States the
order didn't explicitly mention Japanese
Americans but there was no question they
were the target Executive Order 9066 rip
people from their homes their jobs their
education their farms and most people
were never able to recover the loss that
they suffered my parents were
incarcerated for four and a half years
two-thirds of the 120 000 Japanese
Americans removed from their homes and
forced concentration camps including
satsuki's parents were American citizens
by birth which in a war supposedly being
fought in the name of Freedom presented
an image problem for the US government
the government was well aware that the
whole experience was a problem the
Roosevelt administration wanted to frame
the removal as orderly Humane and above
all necessary the government created a
new Department the war relocation
Authority or WRA to handle the removal
and more importantly document it through
propaganda films pamphlets and news
photographs they thought that
documenting it would demonstrate the
government's Goodwill and service one of
the wra's high-profile hires was
Dorothea Lang and of course Lang was
really made famous by her 1930s Great
Depression photographs for the farm
Security Administration in 1942 the WRA
tester with photographing the
Japanese-American removal process in
California Lang photographed the rapid
changes happening in Japanese-American
communities including japanese-owned
farms and businesses shutting down she
photographed families in front of the
homes they owned
children attending school for only a few
more weeks this final game between
friends and a last minute barbecue her
captions often noted how close in time
they were taken prior to evacuation
weeks then days then hours before
removal to the camps and the baggage
piled up on the day of removal
she captured the anxiety the distress
but also captured kind of the Dignity of
how nicely dressed people were you know
they've got their hats and coats and
ties on and their high heels on photos
like this one weren't approved for
circulation by the WRA they weren't very
friendly to her once they saw how she
was narrating visually the story this
photo along with many prints of Langs
have one word written across them in
cursive impounded internal WRA memos
from 1942 revealed that the Army was
deeply concerned about Lang's photos
they described her as highly emotional
and her negatives were surrendered and
the prince impounded by order of the
press relations officer for the WRA
major Norman Beasley of the
approximately 700 photos Lang took for
the WRA around 80 are singled out as
impounded since the WRA owned the rights
to all of Lang's photos and army
permission was necessary to publish any
of them it's unclear what exactly the
distinction was but the impounded images
seemed to fall into a couple of
categories
one was photos of the removal process
that included armed U.S soldiers so this
photo showing satsuki's mom shizuko was
impounded this one from another angle
wasn't this photo shows soldiers
boarding Japanese Americans onto buses
to the so-called assembly centers
temporary prisons used while the
concentration camps were built that
included race tracks in disuse where
Japanese Americans were housed in horse
stalls a lot of these photos were
labeled impounded too my parents were in
a racetrack just outside of San
Francisco my mother's pregnant placed
inside of these horse stables so she had
to endure the horse stables while she
was in this very fragile condition and
you know it's a dehumanizing process
the other types of photos labeled
impounded were images of incarcerated
Japanese Americans waiting in line for
food at the assembly centers and
Japanese Americans wearing U.S army
uniforms other impounded photos don't
fall into a clean category like this one
of a Buddhist priest locking the doors
of his church before evacuation she
they're being victimized but also held
onto the humanness of who they were
while she was working for the government
she was also working for the subjects of
her photographs and I think that's why
it was obvious that the government had
to impound those pictures for the
duration of the war in July 1942 the WRA
released Lang from the program just four
months after she started they withheld
most of her photos from the public for
the rest of the war both the ones marked
impounded and the others with a few
exceptions like this WRA pamphlet
relocation of Japanese Americans that
included a few Lang photos when asked in
the early 1960s about her wartime
experience Lang said they had wanted a
record but not a public record
Lang wasn't the only WRA photographer
whose photos were impounded these images
by press photographer Clem Albers who
also briefly worked for the WRA were
given the same label the WRA did endorse
other photos at the time most notably
from photographer Ansel Adams whose
photos from the manzanar Concentration
Camp depicted happy smiling faces and
Grand Western landscapes
as opposed to the more candid approach
in Lang's images
Dorothea Lang she understood that
Humanity was comprised not just of happy
smiling faces but also those that are
fearful apprehensive amidst a whole
process that sought to dehumanize them
to take away their Humanity by 1943 the
government acknowledged that no known
acts of sabotage Espionage or fifth
column activity were committed by the
Japanese before or after Pearl Harbor
but the last camps weren't closed until
1946. the year after Japan surrendered
that year satsuki's father who had been
held in a separate Camp during the war
reunited with them in a Detention
Facility in Crystal City Texas so my
earliest recollection is being on the
train leaving Crystal City so it was
1946 when our family was reunited
that same year U.S president Harry
Truman terminated the WRA and all of its
records including tens of thousands of
photos were moved into the national
archives in Washington DC
it would take another 25 years for
Lang's WRA photographs to be widely seen
by the public when her former assistant
requested they be pulled from the
national archives for a 1972 exhibit by
the California Historical Society
Executive Order 9066 the exhibit toured
the country and was featured in a 1972
NBC TV documentary Guilty by reason of
race
I think the fact that it was Dorothea
Lang that chronicled what happened her
notoriety and the fact that the photos
were released after they had been
suppressed brought a lot of validation
the photos revealed for many the cruelty
Unleashed by Roosevelt's executive order
they were also published in a book of
the same name the book like the exhibit
showed photos of the removal process
next to headlines and quotes from the
time like this one from a Los Angeles
examiner article from 1943. EO 9066 the
exhibit I learned of it through the
publication of the images and the text
it helped to Galvanize Our Generation
the third generation's efforts towards
redress and reparations that movement
finally resulted in reparations for
survivors of the camps when U.S
president Ronald Reagan signed the civil
liberties Act of 1988. this action was
taken without trial without jury it was
based solely on Race here we reaffirm
our commitment as a nation to equal
justice under the law
nearly 50 years after the government had
violated 120 000 individual people civil
liberties the U.S admitted it had made a
mistake
so I took a picture of my mom she must
have been in her 70s standing in front
of that photograph taken by Dorothea
lank this is shortly after reparations
she felt like it was concrete evidence
about her history and what happened to
her it gave her permission to talk more
about her experience
she has a photograph of a grandfather
and a grandson in manzanari and she shot
it going upward so the humans stand
immense in front of the Sierra Nevadas
the mountains she also shows the older
people who suffered most in the camps
and the children the future Generations
continuity that we have a future here in
this country her photographs
demonstrated the complexity of Human
Relationships around oppression and
resistance
pretty much all of Lang's photos of
Japanese Americans in 1942 have their
own whole story behind them like this
one of the wanto shokai grocery store in
Oakland California Lang wrote in the
caption that the owner tatsuro Masuda
hung this sign outside of his family's
store the day after the attack on Pearl
Harbor masudo was born in California his
father had emigrated from Japan in the
1890s and opened the family store in
1916. win Lang took this photo in March
1942 the masudas had closed the store
following Roosevelt's executive order
they were placed in a concentration camp
in Arizona this photo taken around 1945
shows tatsuro with his family after they
were released from the camp thanks so
much to Jerry naruo tatsuro's nephew for
sharing these photos of the Masuda
family with us as always there's more in
the description including a link to the
collection of Lang's WRA photos with the
word impounded written on the print
which are held at the UC Berkeley
Bancroft library and a link to Satsuki
Ina's award-winning documentary about
her family's incarceration during World
War II from a silk cocoon